Avengers infinity war is an event of
cosmic significance both in our world
and in the Marvel Cinematic Universe for
us it's one of the biggest blockbusters
of all time an unprecedented culmination
of 10 years and 18 movies leading up to
a gigantic finale but for the characters
of the MCU infinity war looks primed to
be their bleakest outing yet and with
the release of its massive first trailer
many fans are increasingly starting to
fear that some of these characters may
not be around for much longer the
biggest potential candidate on the
chopping block is also the most powerful
member of the team Paul Bettany's
synthetic life-form vision key to the
theory of visions impending demise is
the fact that the exact thing that gave
vision life in Avengers age of Ultron is
forehead embedded mine stone is one of
the six powerful Infinity stones Thanos
has spent the last decade plotting his
way across the universe to acquire you
know I don't know what this is I know
it's not of this world the powered Loki
staff gave you your abilities but it's
true nature is a mystery before creation
itself there were six singularities and
the remnants of these systems were
forged into concentrated ingots infinity
stone one shot in the trailer has vision
sprawled on the ground in evident defeat
having his forehead violently probed by
one of Thanos his allies which suggests
that Thanos is going to get his hands on
the stone and if this doesn't end
visions life outright he probably won't
last long against Thanos and his horde
without his powers in a storytelling
sense it would make sense to take vision
out of commission for the big Thanos
fight the vision is immensely powerful
so much so that the movies have
pointedly neglected to use him during
certain battle scenes in a similar
fashion to the way they've sometimes
sidelines the Hulk visions new more
human form and his romance with Scarlet
Witch also raises suspicions that the
end is near for him it's a classic move
they remind you why you love the
character and that may stick the knife
in sometimes literally
[Music]
honestly it wouldn't be a surprise if
many of Marvel's heroes met their ends
and shocking ways in infinity war beyond
the actors expiring contracts and the
fact that the team's mass extinction was
already teased in Avengers age of Ultron
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige has been
vocal in his belief that the studio
needs to move forward with new
characters and new ideas
he told Vanity Fair if Marvel is going
to survive they have to start making
movies with characters who are a little
different they have to start allowing
characters to die it increasingly looks
like that time of reckoning is now not
only have the movies been building to a
fatal conclusion with the mad Titan
Thanos the comics in which the story is
based saw fairness getting away with
lots and lots of murder of some very
recognizable names at least for a while
and Marvel's the Infinity Gauntlet
miniseries Thanos used the unprecedented
power of the collected Infinity stones
which are called infinity gems in the
comics to effortlessly blink half of the
living creatures in the universe
out of existence including heroes like
the Fantastic Four and several Avengers
and when the surviving heroes confronted
them he pretty much wrecked all of them
- with that comic book history in mind
could this be what infinity war is
building - it was previously said that
the subtitle for the fourth Avengers
movie hasn't been released because it
himself is a spoiler does the title
refer to the Avengers defeat it's Disney
pulling and Empire Strikes Back where
all the heroes get their butts kicked
was Mark Ruffalo telling the truth after
all wait till you see this next one
everybody to do well maybe we'll know
for sure when Avengers infinity war
finally hits theatres on May 4th 2018
can you even stand it thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
you